joe biden's poll numbers are just
absolutely abysmal they continue to be
abysmal even a new fox news poll that
shows joe biden up at 47
in terms of approval rating still finds
that about 60 of americans don't want
him to run again 52 disapprove of his
handling of covid only 46 approved 58
percent disapprove of joe biden on the
economy 54 disapprove of him on foreign
policy on border security 59 disapprove
only 37 percent approve
and asked
who they would vote for if the 2024
presidential election were held today
only 36 said they would vote for joe
biden 60
said they would definitely or probably
vote for someone else these are abysmal
numbers for the current president of the
united states by the way kamala harris's
numbers are no better she is at 43
approval rating
and right now the survey asks about
generic congressional ballot if the
election for congress were held today
who they would vote for republicans
narrowly edge out the democrats 44 to 43
what that really means because people
don't like saying that they're going to
vote for the republican party is the
republicans in a wipeout
this this poll by the way is actually
one of the stronger polls for joe biden
of of recent measure a lot of the other
polls have been down in the mid to low
30s and the media are beginning to catch
on to this chuck todd over at nbc news
he says that joe biden is no longer seen
as competent or effective yeah no joke
there
president biden's news conference on
wednesday was designed to kick off a
second year reset of his presidency
cap recaptures political identity if you
will but our mb our new nbc news poll
suggests mr biden does need a reset
because he's lost his identity a bit
he's no longer seen as competent and
effective
no longer seen as a good
commander-in-chief or perhaps most
damaging as easy going and likable in
fact just five percent of adults say mr
biden has performed better than expected
as president
okay when chuck todd is off the biden
train that train is just derail there's
no one left on the train it is off the
tracks like in the fugitive harrison
ford is running away from it and is
going right into a ravine and it is it
is a bad situation for the body
administration the only funny part about
that quote from from chuck todd is that
he thinks that joe biden was ever seen
as radically competent or effective
hussein is not donald trump but that is
not the same thing as being seen as
competent or effective meanwhile over on
cbs they're having the same experience
they had a focus group participants were
asked whether they think that america is
better off for the last year under joe
biden it went very very poorly again for
joe biden in this cbs focus group
during the course of the pandemic we've
been listening to americans through zoom
to get their thoughts on covid the
economy and how the government is
handling it all on friday we check back
in with six of them
who feels like we are in a better place
now than we were a year ago show of
hands
[Music]
no one believes we're in a better spot
now
well that's not great for joe biden
meanwhile the person is coming under
fire because somebody needs to come
under fire for this if you're the biden
administration someone has to go under
that bus the person who's being
criticized most often is ron clayne ron
clayne is the current white house chief
of staff they're actually a couple of
them he is the radical chief of staff he
spends all day on twitter and for all
the talk about how trump was constantly
on twitter ron clayne is just a twitter
devotee he spends all day long just
retweeting allies of president biden and
trying to tweet his way through it it's
become sort of an internet meme when joe
biden has a bad day which these days is
every single day ron claim has to tweet
his way through it he just has to spend
his days trying to get through that well
howie kurtz reported over on fox news
that joe biden is now offering to do
interviews on behalf of ron claim that
is always a very bad sign for you when
things are going so badly that your boss
is having to come out and say that he
has your back
and your boss is the president of the
united states that is that means you are
doing a terrible job so here's how he
curtis reporting this one
ron clay knew based on my reporting when
he took this job that this day would
come
that he knew that the low poll numbers
and the voting rights defeat would make
him a target he kind of looks it is like
being an nfl coach where you turn on
talk radio everyone's talking about uh
all the stupid things that you did and
he's consulted with former chiefs of
staff i can report that president biden
has seen this coverage that he's backing
his top aide and he's offered to do
interviews on claims behalf
okay that's hysterically funny first of
all it's bad politics if one of your
advisors has become the face of your
failure and you have the ability as
president of the united states to take
that person out of the rotation and then
to say listen we'll keep ron around
because we still think he has valuable
advice to offer but we've decided to
shift directions
i mean if joe biden wishes to save his
presidency he needs to make moves like
actually moving ron clayne out of
position of influence instead ron clayne
is still online tweeting like right now
he just retweeted for example benji
starlin benji starlin is a reporter over
at nbc news of course he's the policy
editor and he retweeted a tweet from
benji sarlins and ron klein
in which starlin quoted joe biden saying
to the us conference of mayors that they
would increase funding for the cobs and
starlin tweeted this is the latest in a
long series biden is actually saying the
thing pundits constantly say he should
and it probably doesn't matter all that
much and ronclain is tweeting that
because the thing is that ron twain a
client doesn't actually want joe biden
to tweet or say these moderate things
right ron clayne wants him to say the
radical thing but there is joe biden
trying to defend ron clayne which is
a power move from a guy who is in the
mid-30s in terms of approval ratings
according to half the polls meanwhile
gensake is trying to quiet the base one
of the big problems for the democrats is
a lot of democrats are off the biden
train jensaki told him over the weekend
you know go have a margarita go for a
spin
the the cultural bubble in which these
folks live is truly incredible that they
think that the vast majority of their
patrons are people who have margaritas
and go to kickboxing class here's here
is jen zaki
my advice to everyone out there who's
frustrated sad angry pissed off feel
those emotions go to a kickboxing class
have a margarita do whatever you need to
do this weekend and then wake up on
monday morning we got to keep fighting
okay um i'm just gonna point out the
vast majority of people who follow
politics in the united states are not
single women who live on the set of sex
in the city have a margarita and go to a
kickbox like what is it what does she
think people do on the weekends it's it
is such a bubble
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content